hi everybody Jessica Clemens here with
some apocalypse talk new rockstars has
partnered with universal home
entertainment to create this video and
give you a special behind the scenes
look at knock at the cabin I'm Mike
shyamalan's latest mystery thriller
knock at the cabin showcases some
amazing Weaponry that you probably never
really thought about until you tune into
their special features now available on
DVD one of the special features is
titled tools of the Apocalypse M Night
the costume designer Carolyn Duncan
production designer Neman Marshall and
prop Master Robbie Duncan discuss how
these regular people made these things
we just have in our day-to-day lives I
Promise by the end of this video you
will be looking at props and weapons and
movies differently when we learn all
about that movie Magic behind it all
like I M Night Shyamalan release knock
at the cabin not too long ago and the
movie follows a small family of three on
vacation that's interrupted by four
strangers who claim they were sent there
to stop the apocalypse but one of the
three family members will have to
sacrifice the other in order to save all
humanity and it must be consensual
that's the whole thing of this movie M9
has been in the game for a long time so
it's no surprise that every detail in
his movies has its own story symbolism
or just message like the Weaponry in
signs it was the baseball bat when
Colleen's dying words were tell Marilyn
to swing away little did he know
swinging away would save his entire
family so M Night isn't playing around
with these props especially when what
could be the embodiment of the Four
Horsemen need weapons to protect
themselves but also to sacrifice each
other when I first saw the movie I was
like these weapons are crazy what are
these but after watching it a second
time you start to realize that each
weapon represents each antagonist you
have to just take a closer look at it
the production designer mentioned that
they had to put themselves in the mind
of the people using the weapons so
they're probably making weapons based on
their own visuals of what they're seeing
them using their own visions of the
Apocalypse but there are also people not
trained to kill so they're grabbing
things that they know or look seemingly
like weapons M Night mentioned grabbing
things from a farm because most farm
tools are pretty dangerous when you use
like a weapon Adrian has what they call
the halberd the two-handed Pole weapon
now Adrian was the chef and there's a
meat cleaver attached at the end of the
pole Sabrina uses the Morning Star which
is normally a club-like weapon and this
one has a bludgeoning device at the end
of it now they made Sabrina and Adrian
the weapons that are more for like
swinging and I think the practicality
comes from both these characters needing
more support in their weapons when
you're swinging weapon that has a
dangling part the impact can be harsh as
well as the meat cleaver these are both
items that are great for swinging and
chopping motions easier for someone not
as strong to wield something super heavy
right I think it's also important to add
that like Adrian the chef using a weapon
like the meat cleaver Sabrina as a nurse
probably know she can heal someone from
her weapons impact rather than like with
a meat cleaver or pitchfork like
Leonard's Leonard was the leader
remember how he sort of represents
guidance so they made him a staff-like
weapon something that really demands
attention in order when waltzed into the
room they called it the sleeper it had
an ax head at the top with a pitchfork
taped to the back so this is literally
just very hardcore and Raymond who quite
literally bludgeoned Andrew years ago
with a beer bottle twice he has a meat
tenderizer attached to his weapon
literally something made to bludgeon
it's almost like history repeating
itself manifested in his own weapon this
is what gets my attention because really
think about it if all directors costume
crop designers and Masters think hard on
their characters they want them to make
the most sense so realistically a gun
just doesn't make sense hey what happens
if you immediately got the gun off of
them like you guys would just all die B
their intention was never to kill just
sacrifice each other so using weapons
that doubled as protection and murderous
tools was necessary and it was something
that wasn't easy to take away from you
see they barely knew what they were
doing they made these weapons because
they're a chef a nurse a teacher a Metro
gas employee but overall we don't know
if their Vision showed them using these
weapons specifically or they grabbed the
most weapon looking thing around them at
the time but in logic it makes sense to
just grab what's near you and pray this
all isn't real so recognizing how
important props are and I hope in every
show you watch you ask if there's logic
in the weapon of choice now like I said
earlier you have to ask yourself in the
beginning of the script process how did
these regular people make these weapons
these are tasks that M Night gave to a
team very early in the film stages
asking how they made them and what they
represent you don't want to leave any
Rock unturned this goes for costumes as
well sometimes something as small as
their outfits or designs can have bigger
meaning which Carolyn Duncan gets into
with the white bags over their faces for
the sacrifice story-wise the hood has to
feel like something that one of them or
all of them made themselves we found
Fabrics that you can see at everyone's
features through them which was
incredibly important tonight see I love
this so let's break it down for its
intensity so earlier in the special
feature M9 even mentions his movies
having symbolism and if you've seen the
devil or the village or Lady in the
Water yeah we know it does but in this
particular instance I want to talk about
the symbolism in the bags Caroline
Duncan calls them hoods and a small
magazine I read a person that mentioned
how hoodies can be linked to death and
destruction embodied as the Grim Reaper
and executioners which completely
reflects the actions they're portraying
in this movie the Death that comes with
the hood is instantaneous but also
before they're killed the frosty white
finish of the hood is immediately
contrasted when the red pulls through
it's almost like he went from innocence
to anger Purity to war it's like day and
night and what makes it more triggering
is you still see their outline features
with the mask on it's not even a
sacrifice anymore it's a public
execution at first you don't know who to
trust or believe as the audience so you
don't know if these people are murderers
with an agenda but it makes it more
personal and More Human After
introducing themselves when you see
their features as they say their final
words before dying in the hoods it's
completely dark but it's that eeriness
that creepiness that draws Us in the
fact that the impact never shows but we
see the tip of the head shake from the
blow the movie Magic of it all these
actions are straight hits to our
Thriller dopamine and this is why I love
Thrillers horror movies any kind of Gore
like this now each member of the group
Eric deduce represents the Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse right so they
originally were like Conquest War famine
and death the end of humanity in this
movie they represent guidance Leonard
the teacher nurturing Adrian the mom and
Chef healing Sabrina the nurse and
Malice Redmond the homophobic with anger
issues Eric says they represent all
aspects of humanity and they had to see
them die to feel their loss per the
Bible Conquest rides with a bow War has
a sword a set of scales for famine and
Death Rides a Pale Horse nothing in
hands in the same vein if Conquest is
like guidance Wars like malice I'd say
though kind of adverse famine could be
nurturing and death could be healing
that would mean that Beau would belong
to Leonard the sword to Redmond the
scales for Adrian and nothing for
Sabrina which actually still works out
and checks out in this movie arguably
Redmond and Leonard had the most
aggressive weapons the Pitchfork could
be launched like a Bose era Raymond's
weapon had a Long Blade at the end like
a sword but couldn't be thrown like
Leonard's Adrian had a two-ended weapon
and would put it down periodically to
play opposite to her role as the
antagonist either feeding when breakfast
or when she's fixing the door her
opposition was always changing Sabrina
who attended to Eric throughout the
movie as a nurse didn't even die with
her weapon in hand she was unarmed
nothing in her hands just like death
that's it for my knock at the cabin
exploring the tools of the Apocalypse
I'm an M Night Shyamalan fan always have
been always will be and I see this movie
again just for the subtle leads because
this is eye-opening after watching the
special features thanks again to
Universal home entertainment for
partnering with new rockstars create
this video These bonus features are
yours to own on digital March 24th and
4K ultra high definition and Blu-ray May
9th let me know in the comments if this
was the end of the world how you would
create a weapon make sure to follow me
at Instagram and Twitter at Lulu
underscore Clements follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching and part of humanity has
been judged
thank you
[Music]